and let's talk about the wuhan institute
of virology so maybe this is a good time
to
try to talk about its history about its
origins about what kind of stuff it
works on
about biosafety levels and about
batwoman yeah
so what what is the honesty of our algae
when did it start yeah so it's a great
question so um after sars won which was
in the early 2000s 2003 2004
there was this effort to um
to enhance as i mentioned before
global capacity including in china so
the wuhan institute of virology had been
around for decades before then
but there was an agreement between the
french and the chinese government
to build a the largest bsl4 lab so
biosafety level four so in these what
are called high containment labs there's
level four which is the highest level
and people have seen that in on tv and
elsewhere where you have uh the the
people in the different in suits and all
of these protections and then there's
level three which is still very serious
uh and uh but not as much as level four
and then level two is just kind of
goggles and and some gloves and maybe
that and maybe a face mask much less so
the french and the chinese governments
agreed that france would help build the
first and and still the largest
bsl4 plus some mobile bsl3 labs and they
were going to do it in wuhan and wuhan
is kind of like china's chicago and i
had actually been it's a different story
i'd been in wuhan
relatively
not that long before the pandemic
broke out and that was why i knew that
wuhan is it's a it's not some backwater
where there are a bunch of yokels eating
bats for dinner every night this is a
really sophisticated wealthy highly
educated and and cultured city and so i
i knew that it wasn't like that even the
juan seafood market
wasn't like some of these seafood
markets that they have in southern china
or in cambodia where i lived for for two
years i mean this it's it was a totally
different thing i'm going to have to
talk to you about some of the including
market just some of the wild food going
on here because you've traveled that
part of the world yeah well let's not
get there yeah let's not get distracted
goodness i was telling you lex before
and this is maybe an advertisement yes
um is having now listened to
a number of your podcasts when i'm doing
long ultra training runs or driving in
the mountains like the really because in
the beginning you have to talk about
whatever it is is the topic but the
really good stuff happens later so so
friends you should listen to the end i
you know i i have to say as i was
telling you before
like when i heard your long podcast with
jerome lanier and he talked about his
mother at the very end i mean just
beautiful stuff so i don't know whether
i can i can match beautiful stuff but
i'm gonna i'm gonna gonna do my best
you're gonna have to find out exactly
stay tuned
so um so france had this agreement um
that they were going to help design and
help build this bsl4
lab in wuhan
and
it was going to be with
french standards and there were going to
be 50 french experts who were going to
work there
and supervise the the work that happened
even after the juan institute of
virology um in in the new location
um uh started
uh started operating but then when they
started building it uh the the french
contractors the the french overseers
were increasingly appalled um that they
had less and less control that the
chinese contractors were swapping out
new things they it wasn't built up to
french standards
so much
that at the end when it was finally
built uh the the the person who was the
vice chairman of the project and a
leading french industrialist named mario
refused to sign off and he said we we
can't um support we have no idea um what
this is whether it's safe or not
and when this this lab opened remember
we were supposed to have 50 french
experts it had one french expert and so
the the french were really disgusted and
actually
when the wuhan institute of virology and
its new location opened in in 2018
two things happened one french
intelligence privately approached u.s
intelligence saying we have a lot of
concerns about the wuhan institute of
virology about its safety and we don't
even know who's operating there is it
being used as a dual use facility
and also in 2018 the u.s embassy in
beijing sent some people down to wuhan
to go and look at well
at this laboratory and they wrote a
scathing cable that josh rogan from the
washington post later got his his hands
on saying um this is really unsafe
they're doing work on dangerous bat
coronaviruses
in conditions where a leak is uh is
possible and so then you mentioned
xiang li and i'll connect that to the
these virologists who i was was was
talking about
so there's a very credible
thesis um that because
um these pathogenic outbreaks happen in
other parts of the world having
partnerships with experts in those parts
in those parts of the world
must be a foundation of our of our
efforts we can't just bring everything
home
because we know that that viruses don't
care about borders and boundaries and so
if something happens there it's going to
come here so
very correctly and we have all kinds of
partnerships um with experts in in these
labs and xiang li
was one of those partners and her
closest relationship was with peter
dazak who's a british i think now
american but the the president of a
thing called eco health alliance which
was getting money from nih and basically
ecohealth alliance was a pass-through
organization and and you know over the
years it was only about six hundred
thousand dollars so almost all of her
funding came from the chinese government
but there's a little bit that came from
the united states
and so she became
their kind of leading expert and the the
point of contact between the wuhan
institute of virology
and um certainly peter dasik but also
also with with others
and that was why in the earliest days of
the outbreak i didn't mention that um i
did mention that there were these
virologists who had this fake certainty
that they knew it came from nature and
it didn't come from a lab and they
called people like me conspiracy
theorists just for raising that that
possibility but when peter dezek was
organizing that effort in february
of 2020 what he said is we need to rally
behind our chinese colleagues and the
basic idea was
these international collaborations are
under threat and i think this was
because of that because peter desick's
basically his his major contribution as
a scientist was just tacking his name on
work that xi jiang li had largely done
um he was defending a lot certainly for
himself and his organization so you
think uh equal health alliance and uh
peter
is less about money it's more about kind
of um almost like legacy because you're
so attached to this work because it's
just not a human level so i i think so i
mean i i've been criticized for being
actually i'm certainly a big critic of
peter daisy
but i've been criticized by some for
being too lenient i mean it's so easy to
say oh somebody they're like an evil
ogre and just trying to do evil and and
cackling in their
in their closet or whatever but i think
for most of us even those of us who do
terrible horrible things
the story that we tell ourselves and we
really believe is that we're doing the
thing that we most believe in i mean i
did my phd dissertation on the khmer
rouge in cambodia they genuinely saw
themselves as idealists they they
thought well we need to
make radical change to build a better
future and the what they described is
what they felt was radical change was
was a monstrous atrocities
so the criticism here of peter
is that
he was uh part of an organization that
was
kind of
well funding an effort that was an
unsafe implementation of a biosafety
level 4
laboratory well
a few things so
what he thought he was doing um
was and then what he thought he was
doing is itself highly controversial
because there's one there that
in 2011
there were i know you've talked about
this with other guests but in in 2011
there were the first
published papers on this now infamous
gain of function uh research and and
basically what they did um both in
in different labs and certainly in the
united states in in wisconsin and in in
the netherlands was they had a bird flu
virus that was that was very dangerous
but not
massively uh transmissive
and they they had a gain of function
process through what's called serial
passage which means basically passing
advice like natural selection but
forcing natural selection by just
passing a virus through a different cell
cultures and then selecting for what it
is that you want
so relatively easily they took this
deadly but not massively transmissive
virus and turned it into in a lab a
deadly and transmissive virus and that
showed that this is really dangerous and
so there were at that point there was a
huge controversy there were some people
um
like richard e bright and mark lipsich
at harvard who were saying um that this
is really dangerous we're in the the
idea that we need to create monsters to
study monsters i think maybe even you
have said that in the past
it doesn't make sense because there's an
unlimited number of monsters and so what
are we going to do create an unlimited
number of monsters and if we do that
eventually the monsters are are going to
get out then there was the peter dasik
camp and he got a lot of funding
particularly from the united states who
said well and and certainly collins and
fauci were supportive of this and they
thought
well there's a safe way to go out into
the world to collect the world's most
dangerous viruses and to poke and prod
them
to figure out how they might mutate how
they might become more dangerous
with the goal
of predicting
future pandemics and that certainly
never happened with the goal of creating
vaccines and treatments
and that largely uh never happened but
that was so peter dezak kind of
epitomized
that uh that second second approach um
and as as you've talked about in the
past in 2014 there was a funding
moratorium in the united states and then
in 2017
that was lifted it didn't affect the
funding that went to the uh to the
eco-health
alliance um so when this happened in
in the beginning and again coming back
to peter's motivations
i don't think um here's the best case
scenario for for peter i'm going to give
you if what i imagine he was thinking
and then i'll tell you what i actually
think
so i think here's what he's thinking um
this is most likely a natural origin
outbreak it it just like sars one again
in peter's hypothetical mind just like
sars one this is most likely a natural
outbreak
we need to have an international
coalition in order to fight it
if we allow
these political attacks to undermine our
chinese counterparts and the trust in
this release relationships that we've
built over many years we're really
screwed because they have the most local
knowledge of these outbreaks and even
though and and this guy gets a lot more
complicated even though there are
basic questions that anybody would ask
and that xi jiang li herself did ask
about
the origins of this pandemic
even though peter dezak and i'll mention
this describe this in a moment
had secret information that we didn't
have that in my mind massively increases
the possibility of a lab incident origin
i peter dezek would like to guide the
public conversation uh in the direction
where i think it should go and in
in support of the kind of international
collaboration that i think is necessary
that's a strong positive discussion
because
it's true
that there's a lot of political bs and a
lot of uh
kind of just
bickering and lies as we've talked about
and so it's very convenient to say you
know what let's just ignore all of these
quote unquote lies and my favorite word
misinformation
and then because the way out from this
serious pandemic is for us to work
together so let's strengthen our
partnerships
and everything else is just like noise
yeah so let's and so then now i want to
do my personal indictment of peter
dayzak because that that's my view but i
wanted to fairly
because i think that that
you know we all tell ourselves stories
and and and i and also when you're a
science communicator um you can't in
your public communications give
every doubt that you have or every
nuance you kind of have to summarize
things and so i think that he was again
in this this benign interpretation
trying to summarize in the way that he
thought the the conversations should go
here's my indictment of peter dayzak and
i uh i i
i feel like uh brutus here but i i i
have not come here to praise um uh peter
dezek because um while peter dezek was
doing all of this and making all of
these statements about well we pretty
much know it's a natural origin and then
there was this february 2020 lancet
letter where it turns out and we only
knew this later that he was highly
manipulative so he was
recruiting all of these people he
drafted the the infamous letter calling
people like me uh conspiracy theorists
he then wrote to people like ralph
barrack and linfa wang who are also very
high-profile virologists saying well
let's not put our names on it so it
doesn't look like we're doing it
even though they were doing it he didn't
disclose a lot of information that they
had it was a strategic move so just uh
in case people are not familiar february
lancel letter
was
uh tldr is a lab league hypothesis
is a conspiracy theory essentially yes
so like with the authority of science
not saying like it's highly likely
saying
it's obvious duh it's uh it's natural
origin everybody else is just uh is
everything else is just misinformation
and look there's a bunch of really smart
people that sign this therefore it's
true yeah not only that so there were um
the people whose 27 people signed that
letter and then after president trump
cut funding to eco health alliance then
he organized 77
nobel laureates to to have a public
letter criticizing that but what peter
knew then
that we didn't fully know is that in
march of 2018 eco health alliance in
partnership with the wuhan institute of
virology and others had applied for a 14
million dollar grant um to darpa which
is kind of like the the vc side of the
venture capital side of the of the
defense department they're kind of where
they do kind of big ideas
by the way as a tiny tangent i've gotten
a lot of funding from darpa they fund a
lot of excellent robotics research and
darpa's incredible and among the things
that they applied for is that we meaning
wuhan institute of virology is gonna go
and it's gonna collect the most
dangerous bat coronaviruses in southern
china
and then we as this as this group are
going to genetically engineer these
viruses um to insert a furin cleavage
site so i think when everyone's now seen
the image of the sarsko v2 virus it has
these little spike proteins these little
things that that stick out which is why
they call it a coronavirus within that
spike protein are these furon cleavage
sites which basically help with get the
virus getting access into our
cells and they were going to genetically
engineer these furon cleavage sites into
these bat coronaviruses the cervical
viruses
and then and so then
a year and a half later what do we see
we see
a bat coronavirus
with a fear and cleavage site unlike
anything that we've ever seen before in
that category of sars like coronaviruses
that well
yes immediate the the darpa very
correctly didn't support that
application
you